okay for people joining this live stream
we are watching leonard's screen here i
think
and uh
we will be talking about
aspects of the future of arrays in
wolfram language
and we have several different projects
running right now and maybe we'll hear
about some of them here because i think
it's been a while since we've had a
meeting we have the data container
project
and we have uh this data set backing
with other things project so maybe maybe
you can
um
uh
define what this is so this is this is
backing data sets with databases is that
correct
um yeah although potentially it is a
more it's a wider approach than just
databases
uh
the essential idea is that
uh you
can
uh back a data set but by various
different backends they can be
flat data or relational or maybe
hierarchical data as mongodb
and the idea is that
we try to generate
the queries
which from data set queries we try to
generate queries in the target language
that would allow you or the users
to essentially use data set query
language
but behind the scenes two yeah okay so
leona this was the original idea of
dataset back when it was originally
conceived this was the idea about how it
would work
so
this is good
um i strongly believe in this idea um
yeah i think there are very good
indications that this uh this is very
fruitful direction
and
i have to say in advance that this is
not orthogonal it is not exclusive
mutually exclusive with data container
and i think that's a very important
point to
agree i i you're right i mean data
container
is
well i mean
they're a
data container is a more lightweight
thing
but
data container will presumably be one of
the
implementation methods relevant to
certain kinds of data sets
like if what's in a data set doesn't
have any of the kind of wrapping the
data container makes useful like being
able to put in units and things like
this
then you don't need data container here
or doesn't i mean as i understand it the
thing with data container
is that it is a translation layer that
allows you to both wrap the contents
deal with missings
and potentially
uh have a formatting of the underlying
data that is not you know you can access
it
using standard part specifications or
whatever but it may be stored in some
different way
is that is that right rob can you speak
to that i mean
that's that's basically right and it's
it's more lightweight in the sense that
it's it's it's intended for
you know much more rectangular data than
what the leonid is trying to work with
although
let's
be realistic i mean most of this data is
going to wind up being rectangular
so while we need to be able to deal with
the special case of it not being
rectangular not really special case the
general case of it not being rectangular
if we can optimize the rectangular case
we're already at the 95 level yeah then
that's that's that's that's what the
data container is is kind of intended to
do is to optimize that case
yeah so uh
so uh returning to this approach that i
am pursuing
uh the idea is that
the
target language can potentially be be
anything
that is behind the backing the
particular backing of a data set
so
it's not necessarily even a query
language is an in the
usual sense like sql or like manga db
query language it can be uh an api like
a set of function calls like for for
example
uh if the
same data container framework
uh exposes certain primitives
uh
like uh selection or like uh group group
by or certain other primitives in its
own way
uh or maybe it proxies to arrow
backing and the exposes arrow primitives
then
uh the uh possible uh target language
could be a set of those function calls
and therefore this approach should allow
people to still use data set query
language without actually knowing we get
it we get it we understand so all the
very good idea
launch let's see what you've got
okay so i originally started with the um
simple flat uh in-memory data that was
like the first phase of my work was to
have a proof of concept
uh with the flat data which simply lives
in memory
uh by flat you mean
that what was rectangular has been
flattened out like a fortran array or
something or what yeah i basically i can
i can quickly show on an example what i
mean so
uh
there was this sample example i was
using which is the
planet's data set which is
almost the same as from the
documentation of data set
and then
jumping to
the
flat data
it looks roughly like this each row
contains
so it's basically a list of associations
each of which
has
a number of unique keys which have some
correspondence to the hierarchical keys
of the original data set
so for example here you can see that
there are two keys with the name mass
but they have different
uh
different prefixes or different
numerical indices and one of them
corresponds to the mass of the moon
while the other one corresponds to the
mass of the planet right so
the mass of the planet the mass of the
moon obviously are at different levels
of the data set in terms of nesting
however once i get it you get it you can
flatten it all out i mean i i personally
i would have done the flattening
differently because i would have just
had the name of the the key
just be the hierarchical series of
of keys that you would need to drill
down to that element
actually this is how it's done this is
how it's done internally but
uh
there are some reasons to prefer
purely technical reasons to prefer
string keys at the end
so
in fact i don't know if i can
if i'm able to show it here
uh maybe not because okay this is a
previous version but the the basic idea
was that the bridging
the bridge between the two
representation is this
object that i call tabular data set
schema
which in some sense is a generalization
of the
data dimensions a notion from the uh
data container although i came to this
from completely
kind of a completely independent needs
just to bridge these things but
conceptually you can think of this as a
generalization of that so what this is
this is a metadata
which
basically tells you
uh
what is the type structure i get it i
get it it tells you how to reconstruct
it i mean this looks incredibly similar
to what i imagine data container will do
yeah and uh
because it's nested you can you can
expand things and you can see
you can see the inner structure okay
question with data container are we also
imagining that we will have a nesting
de-nesting uh uh possibility for data
container
that's probably for rob but i have a few
i have a few ideas about that but
what the rob yes so so that's that's
that's a lot of what i've already
written is the you know so you have
nested associations and it
it de-nests or flattens and and comes
back and okay so how similar is what
you've done to what linda's showing us
here
it's it's
it's it's a little bit orthogonal it's
mine is is very much set at a
rectangular scheme so i'm not you know
i'm not creating
you're creating new keys or something
because i'm assuming stuff is
rectangular
wait wait that was the question i was
asking
what i'm asking is
you are not nesting and de-nesting in
this way so leonard has something here
okay so that is clearly technology
that's useful but technology you can
immediately use rob
i mean you could one aspect of data
container could be this thing is really
supposed to be hierarchical but it is
going to be manipulated as
non-hierarchical because that's our
efficient back end
well but i i think the point is that
with any of these things there needs to
be sort of a uh
right i mean there's sort of this
the what what is the space of schemas
that you're allowing right and in the
case of data container it's allowing
schemas that are rectangular-ish this is
allowing a different set of schemas
right so this nesting stuff is a whole
other class of schemas that requires a
whole other interface for
for dealing with
yes but then look there's two things
there's the front-end schema as the
back-end schema the front-end schema is
what what
what is the surface level thing that
will be the result of normal basically
and the back-end thing is into what is
this being turned for final manipulation
um
stephen maybe
maybe
a few things will become more
uh maybe more clear or more uh packed
with more information once i discuss a
little bit about
the relational backing for
these uh i see that i see the idea here
this looks good yeah so this is what you
were talking about yeah that there is a
direct translation between
the keys and the what you suggested as
essentially
uh a satellite i don't understand why
moons is missing from the key
designation there
why moon is what sorry missing from the
underscore mass underscore nine
um why is that on the key on the left
why are you not including everything you
need to resolve where that key
lives in the whole structure
well um
because um
i think it's uh
in this particular case it's a matter of
uh style but for relational backing for
example
uh the
keys that are in the database they are
string names anyway so you will anyway
need some way to translate some some
mapping so here
i simply maintain that mapping within
this schema and separate from but that's
incredibly similar to what's happening
in data container you're maintaining an
outer schema
i mean there's the outer schema that
you're maintaining
and then you've got an inner schema that
is that raw schema there that's the
underscore mass underscore nine and that
must be so let's please get some
consistency in how we do this
and what the names of the keys are and
stuff like this
does that make sense
yes but uh
i mean i mean
i guess the question leonard is is there
any reason you couldn't name that key
mass underscore nine
something like you know moons underscore
a
um
yeah i guess uh
there is no
there is no deep reason for not doing
that right i mean maybe there's a string
length limit or something i mean but
that's sort of how the compiler does
does de-mangling is it it sort of puts
the types together with underscore and
it's it's much easier to tell what
you're dealing with when you look at you
know some internal function that's just
created numbers there let me explain one
reason why it's not a good idea in my
view
the thing is that when you run the
queries you end up with the data sets
which have different structure
because certain levels collapse certain
levels get you know they disappear new
levels appear
and so
if i tie
these um
names to the original
nested structure of the original data
set then i'll have to bother to rename
them every time when i do the
data transfer data transformation
while what i prefer to do is that
what changes is the metadata and the
mapping
but the underlying column names remain
the same as they were originally okay
but look rob has must have the same
issue that is if he extracts a row from
or a column let's say from one of his
tabular you know rectangular objects
that column let's say it's an
association of associations
that
column do you rename the thing based on
the underlying on on the second level
association's keys or do you keep both
levels of keys
well i
oh okay it's for you no go ahead
um no no there was uh robert was a
question for you i guess right yeah so
the way you know and again this
since i started working the tabular
stuff i haven't done that much
much
you know deep thought into or actually
any real work on it because i've been
doing other things but i think
i think the thing too so if you say
eliminate a level in doing a part we'll
we'll kind of
you know we we remap the schema the
rectangular
and and
basically change the name
name of how that appears
though that would still so if we have
say a name dimension level which is say
mass
okay that's going to stay as mass
as a name dimension level
yeah but you see i maybe
one question maybe because we before we
spend too much time
into this topic
are these keys actually visible or
they're just meant to be used internally
for indexing
no these keys are only the the keys
which you see as string is they are only
visible they are not visible for the end
user at all
okay all right fine
okay i i see the argument for leonard
to have this you know this level only
type key
and i think it's reasonably convincing
so i'm okay with that um
yeah i was i was going to show some
examples to convince you about this but
i guess we can probably move on if i'm
convinced at least i'm convinced i don't
know the
um
yeah
what is vector is vector list
uh yes vector is a list uh essentially
it suggests the
vector because the data set has a type
system and the type system of dataset
has essentially
uh four major containers which are a
sock vector tuple and struct
and so these names they follow the
conventions of the dataset type system
okay so wait a second that data set type
system has never been exposed to
anybody right this is the the the
distinction i i i haven't seen this but
the same distinction exists in the
compiler as well and i can guess from
the names but it is i mean basically
there are two types of lists there are
lists where you know it's a sort of
variable length thing i have a million
records and here they are then there's
lists where it's like this is the x and
this is the y or this is the latitude
this is the longitude where it's a fixed
length thing
exactly right so so tuples of the second
vector is the first and it's the same
distinction between acell construct
presumably yeah in fact i have a slide
where basically
there is um
um
there is this
you see there is this small table yep
that's that's exactly what we just
said right yeah yeah that's exactly what
christopher said
and so um
yes you're at stephen that explicitly
this type system has not been
exposed to the user in a sense it was
not documented but if you look at every
input form at any data set it contains
the type expressed
right but we need to not
make the mistake of saying just because
it's been there internally this is what
we're going to now expose i mean i
understand the functionality is fine
i'm just i don't think the names are
right and i think you know
yeah we just have to be a little bit
careful yeah so we'll have to
yeah go ahead
oh sorry i was gonna ask quick questions
so so do you know i i assume that this
that the schema that the data set type
system
you know figures out i assume that's
also it's used to make the sort of uh
output form for data set like the
visualization absolutely so if if the
output form i mean most of the time like
maybe 90 to 95 of the time the output
form of the data set is correct and
there isn't any kind of weird
glitchiness to it does that sort of mean
that that's the fraction of the time the
type system pretty much figures it out
yes sir
okay
uh in fact there are two ways uh one way
is direct
which is uh
it's called
um
basically not inferencing by but
deducing the time so you take the data
as it stands and you deduce the type
and then the second one is through this
type inferencing rules and the 90
percent something percent of cases type
inferencing just works
and then you don't have to re measure
the data essentially rededuce the time
okay
okay this from the wild data type
deduction is what semantic import was
supposed to do
uh
well
maybe maybe i know that currently it
still lives in the data set cohen base
okay i'm telling you that's what that
symantec import was supposed to do that
i'm not sure how successful it's been so
semantic imports much broader though
because it also does things like trying
to interpret quantities and
entities and so on i mean the the more
the more basic thing of just being able
to infer this is a list of numbers this
is an association of strings to to
integers now that that already exists
inside of data set and it's much lighter
weight simpler
okay but okay so look look in terms of
naming and structuring and so on we
clearly need the compiler types the data
set types these all have to agree
uh well naming and so on steven but
compiler types are rather different
in the sense that
a data set type system is very much
tied to
what dataset does
which is
a higher level in some ways
and more kind of a little bit more i
don't get so i don't think that's right
i think that look in the end you're
going to want to make c library calls to
random low-level data manipulation
systems and it's going to be super
useful if those if the data types that
you're putting out from data set just
align with the data types in the
compiler
um yeah but how would you express uh
well i know that it's possible to
express things in the compiler when you
have
for instance
some vector of vectors of things sure
but but the thing is here it's enough to
just say okay the container is a sock or
the container is a struct you don't have
to
say it's struct of what because it it's
basically well christopher how would you
do that in the compiler wait sorry i
just i i don't understand how the data
set
type doesn't work so if you have a
struct container type do not have to
specify the types of its right elements
expressions um yeah well you do have to
specify but it's sort of inside
uh
i mean if you look at the data set type
so at least i mean i'm not sure if this
is the issue i mean in compiler types
you can definitely have parameterized
types so you know you can have a a list
or you can for example you can have uh
what's effectively a struct type they're
called association tuples in the
compiler
where
you have a bunch of keys and each key
has an associated type with it
yeah maybe maybe it's possible but i
mean here what's uh kind of clear and
good about this is at least uh as it
seems to me is that
uh these namings they just say
essentially
what is the container and there are only
four types of containers
this is a simple thing right we should
make these names agree between the
compiler and data sets
and data container by the way they
should all agree
because that way first because that's
good design
and second of all because i think it's
going to be the case that the backing
that you want for both data set and data
container is going to want to go to raw
c code using
you know the library loading mechanism
that the compiler now has am i confused
christopher am i confused about the use
of those data types of things well i i
i'm not i'm not totally sure i mean so
first of all i mean
for the for the design perspective just
you know it makes the internal code
nicer if the names line that's like you
know sure maybe maybe so
um although i'm not sure
how many how hard that refactor is
but um in terms of like
the practical case of trying to interact
with compiled code
i'm not sure how useful it is to have
those type systems align i mean because
if nothing else it'll be very simple to
write you know some some five line
function that takes a data set type and
converts it to a compiled type i mean it
would just be i know why not just do
that automatically i mean why not okay
maybe a broader question sorry just a
quick quick question is is this going to
be exposed anywhere like is there a
reason why for users we want to make the
types design or is it just for our sort
of internal consistency
um
well i would guess that this some form
of this schema thing will probably
eventually be exposed
yeah that's what i think too uh but but
the thing is right now
dataset has its type system and even if
it's used only mostly for
representational purposes it's still
used throughout the code base so the
thing is
uh
this schema object here it it it is very
much like intrinsically tied to data set
so if we start naming these things
differently we will immediately create
certain impedance mismatch between data
set type system
and the compiler time system so then
if we do it this way then we should do
the complete thing and rewrite data set
type system using the compiler types
i'll just mention it's a little more
complicated because for example the
you know the vector
the vector type he has here in the
compiler that might be
this thing we have which is called list
factor which can have any type inside
but
but for more specific types it might be
you know might be an array type like a
packed array type or a numeric array
type
um and the compiler distinguishes
between those two
okay but that's exactly the thing that
here it's uh it's abstract on a data set
level of abstraction okay
look look here's what we need we need
something which is called something like
you know data set list vector or i don't
know what the right term is
okay and your five line program that you
just described right
that can be the thing that is for
example the you know the type union
specification or something
um
you know type uh
um
you know
defined in in terms of compiler types
that is
that type
that the data set is dealing with does
that make sense
yeah
yeah i yeah i mean one one thing is i'm
not sure
i think part of the thing is just that
you know because it's called the data
set type system i think there's an urge
to make it you know align with the other
type system you have but i i don't know
if it is type system right i mean yeah
yes i mean it might be sort of a vague
schema i mean either you call it a
schema in which case then you know
there's no interest in making it line
with the compiler type system because
that might really be what it is
and oh yeah all right let's get off this
topic i think
my tentative suggestion would be that
you invent some type names
that are then written
and you see whether they can be written
in terms of compiler types whether we
can have a definition of com you know in
terms of compiler types that gets to
those data set types
perhaps that's silly i don't know
uh well one thing stephen one thing to
to to sort of the final thing i wanted
to mention here is that i think
given that this schema at the moment is
not exposed yet
we can somewhat postpone this decision
but this this question but keep it in
mind that we have i don't like it i
think they should be renamed but anyway
all right keep going
okay
uh
so uh
so last time uh when we had the stream
was this approach
uh
i was showing uh example of the
uh
relational database man kind of manually
imported
into
uh
wolfram language using this entity
queries and using certain
uh
manual schema that
uh that i was using to to instruct how
to do that
now um
the
since then i've been working on
relational backing so i moved away from
the
uh flat the original kind of two example
of flat data in memory and moved to
uh properly relational data
to both because it's both important uh
uh this is an important thing on its own
but it's also an important use case to
illustrate the general approach
uh
and
um uh
the
uh
the the relational model is more
complicated to
for this mapping than the flat model
because the data is spread across
several tables which are connected to
each other through
relational
constraints
and so there is a bigger impedance
mismatch
uh between these two models right show
us show us some examples
yeah unfortunately for for the demo i
have to apologize for
uh some examples of broken
uh well some of them but let me show you
at least what what works and then for
what doesn't i i will just show what
should be there okay there's a database
is this is this generated by us this
picture is this just some uh
no and that's uh you it's not the first
time you ask uh i have to say that we
have
uh we have a function
which which is somewhere in the
experimental functions and databases
which i wrote which does somewhat
similar
so we'll make it a priority to expose
this and design reviews
so that we yeah i mean it doesn't look
very difficult
after all yeah exactly and we can we can
even actually do it better in the sense
that we can do lots of these things
interactive rather than just the
the gif
uh we we can we can make things clear
yeah right and with graph layout yeah
exactly
so um well this is connecting to
database this by the way this is a
database which is the one we use for
documentation for
can i see the connection because you
know one of the things that i keep on
wanting to see happen
is
all the stuff where we have i can't even
remember it now entity function and so
on
this really isn't right it's really the
wrong way around it really should be
that we have this database object and
you keep poking it with things
well in some sense data set backed by
database will become uh something close
to what you have in mind i think okay
all right fine um
so that's how this connecting looks
right now
basically there is a file
was this days because it's sqlite
and then you create a relational
database object output which is yeah
right and you register it as an entity
as an entity right and all of that stuff
should go away i mean in other words
what you should be doing is just saying
i've got this data set it is backed by
this database
and i don't have to register any entity
stores or anything that stuff is all
happening behind the scenes
when i do queries with respect to the
data set yeah i think we will
probably
it's not going to be very hard to to
hide it all all these steps so that
um this will be really as simple as as
you as you as you say
um
uh now uh
the
interesting thing is uh
i was partly showing this before but
that wasn't on one of the internal
meetings and we didn't have much time to
discuss this
so
uh so basically
now we can we can generate the
schema which is the similar object to
the one i had for the flat data
although it's more complicated but the
structure is similar
from the spec which effectively shows
you from which tables which fields you
want to import
and what should be the structure of the
nested data set at the end
and of course uh i will immediately
mention that this hierarchy
definitely is uh representing partially
the natural hierarchy that exists for
those tables
and how they're connected
in the data set but there is more than
one way how you can cut
in this sorry in in the database i
understand right it's the different
slices of the yes bunch of relations
this is essentially some kind of
foliation or slice of the of the of the
set of relations in the database
yes and and while uh the difference here
is interesting because
data set uh
in certain ways is more powerful
well how i would put it this way
uh for certain kind of queries dataset
is better suited than
uh the straightforward entity language
or even like sql for relational
databases because it automates a number
of things
and data set also allows you to do
certain things even laser than
uh than data the relational database
queries
so uh by making this cut here and
cutting this uh relational database in
certain way
we are making certain queries harder but
certain other queries we're making
easier and that's the trade-off so
apart from sure just the general
familiarity of data set users was data
set query language because they
hopefully they will not be they will not
need to learn
either sql or even the entity language
to express these queries but also the
queries themselves in some cases will be
even shorter
uh
now uh
so when we execute this i hope it's not
gonna
so you get back similar object
uh
but now
uh it has
certain other metadata
which for each layer so effectively here
is the situation the uh
the data set has now several nested
layers
and
some of these layers are attached to a
database table for example
here we have the employees database
table but it is spread across two layers
one is a sock which represents the
collection of records and the other one
inside one is struct which represents a
single record
and so
we have i don't know if you can see
the pop-up yeah not
yes
so the idea is that you can attach to
certain layers
uh the symbolic queries in this case
this is an intermediate representation
we use for
databases which is not entity but which
is
roughly on a similar level of it's
slightly lower level than entities but
it's much higher level than
any other internal representations we
have uh and so it's an inerrant internal
query which represents in this case uh
this employees table was there was was
the
was the
fields renamed in a certain way
and now if you expand some
uh if you expand certain
uh internals
you can see that other tables like
payments and orders
they also have a similar structure
can i summarize i mean basically you're
saying
given this schema
and this schema is somewhat similar to
what we expect the data container schema
to look like
given the schema you have some mapping
that tells you for every element of the
schema how would you actually get the
data associated with that element from
the underlying database
um
yes but uh the crea the crucial part
here is that um
you connect not necessarily a single
field to a database
but you connect a level of a data set i
understand to understand so you have an
optimized way of getting this but i mean
in the end some particular element in
your schema you say i want to get the
you know customer whatever you know
payment history or something
in the end customer payment history
is
obtained as the following sql query i
mean it's in the end that's what's going
to happen underneath yes yes and in fact
this is what's going to happen right
here
down below in this
um in this
demo
so
so here is the
i have a function well obviously it's
now still it will all be
hidden by certain interface now it's uh
some separate functions
but uh uh this shows how
the
uh full data extraction query for this
schema
looks like and it's a
pretty big symbolic expression
now
when we
uh
so when we extract the data
then what's happening
well let's uh
taking some time but hopefully
it will
still work in the end it was working for
me
before
um
so this is supposed to generate the
uh full
sql
necessary for extract
uh fully data from
this understand and then it's going to
return a sub data yeah and um so in this
case it returned this
yes this this data set and if
actually i didn't try it but
if i try
uh for example
i have some
some some length uh kind of a part
extraction functionality so
uh we should probably be able to
just do
um
so if it's just
uh for example customers
uh
customers
and then still let's say we only want
uh
what the heck is that down thing well
it's uh
i didn't know how to uh
how to explain or how to express that
uh i want to go down to
the inner layer without exposed to what
isn't it the same as all well all is not
exactly the same because all will can
all will keep
uh the outer
layer
and i want to strip it
like this
basically
um
well
uh
yes
well anyway i i'm not probably uh i just
wanted to show that uh i although i
didn't try this but wait wait a second
orliness is a feature of the actual data
what you're manipulating is the skeleton
the schema yes so all enos is different
and i mean it's all
is just like a node
on this you know in some graph it's just
like like this there's nothing there
there's no
and you happen to be
i mean you could simply canonicalize
your schema that whenever you have
something where it say well don't do
anything here it removes that from the
schema so you have have a non-canonical
form of schema in which you say well i'm
i this level what do i say about this
level oh just use all of that level okay
you can simplify the schema by removing
that
because you don't have to think about it
conceptually is a different thing um yes
uh but what you
what you are describing is more like a
slice or well slices internal but part
operation effectively acting on data set
while here um yeah but but but you're
right this is more uh this is more just
to see the universe of the schema just
how they look
right this is operating on the skeleton
yeah this is skeleton
right and that that the
operations on the skeleton will be
relevant for data container as well
yeah i guess so
right so so for example you do
operations on the skeleton and the whole
point is as you change the skeleton the
animal altogether moves so to speak that
is if you say i want to rearrange the
skeleton in this way
then you can
you know you can apply that change that
transformation of the skeleton to the
actual data
in fact this is uh exactly what is
happening for
uh when i'm
the process of data set query
compilation in this approach
is exactly the process of manipulating
uh this skeleton or this schema yes
right
and from that from that we generate the
final data transformation
uh that is supposed to operate on
underlying data that's the idea
it's exactly it's exactly that
uh i was just trying to see whether we
can yeah well that's probably not meant
to
uh anyway uh it doesn't matter so the
thing is whenever you have the
uh when i have this schema
there are ways to extract the data at
the end and then i don't show it here
but uh it's still
it's going to be again
behind the data set interface but the
user will see the unflattened dataset so
the user will not
obviously see
this uh huge flat data they'll see the
uh what they
are used to see here
for the so uh so well here is where
things are not
not good currently
i was going to show certain
uh
certain compilation of certain queries
one was uh rather simple was the slice
which is
uh the um uh
uh extracting certain parts of the
schema and it was supposed to add okay
okay okay fine but but what is slice
slice is the version of part used
internally for data set and the reason
it was introduced
mainly was to take care of the missings
and also to not bark on things which go
out of range
uh
because
because because basically for the
purposes of data set part operation was
a little bit too rigid in in how it
reacted it
it was complaining for going out of
range and
for certain things where we would
instead maybe want missings
i understand i mean that's kind of a
subtle thing which we need to deal with
i mean that's part of the whole calculus
of missing is a part
that i mean just like with lookup for
example in the data set you've got
failure objects rather than
in
yeah that's tricky
exactly and also the other thing which
is good about slice is that it is an
operator so
it's it's very declarative
uh it can be
uh actually this was a in general this
was the one of the
uh internal design
uh principles of data set that the query
that dataset generates
is pretty declarative
so
and this is uh this is important here in
this context because
what i'm taking as a source is not the
query as written here but the query as
well here maybe but in general it will
be the query that data set spits out
when it compiles the original user's
query into its internal form
and that's what yeah
and so here is for example this um
here's the query that how one of the
queries that the user might write which
is they are selecting certain employees
on one level then they pick customers
and for the customers they select all
customers who come from france
but the actual query that is generated
from data set is different
you can see it looks more like this
so
it compiles this original query into
things involving right composition
slices
and
some selects are mapped can we zoom out
for a second big picture here sure okay
the
you know what we're trying to do is
you've got a database it's got some
schema
you want to define a slice through that
schema
that you want to map into a data set
first point
right
yes
okay so we've got some function that
takes
in this case i mean you know what we
want to do is to back data sets with all
kinds of stuff with files with you know
data relational databases with with you
know whatever okay
so what you have is a converter that
goes from the relational database which
sings and dances and has tentacles all
over the place
and you want to take the particular
slice that you are going to kind of the
the freeze-dried slice that you are
going to be examining in your data set
exactly right yes so first function we
need is the thing that maps from the
original schemas and that's the thing
you were showing a couple of slides ago
from the original schemas to essentially
the data set schema
and so that's first thing so second
thing is once you've defined that
mapping
and you've created your data set
extracted from the relational database
then
all of the queries that are your sort of
traditional queries that run in a data
set you by extreme cleverness are going
to compile all those queries into sql
basically in the end and
is that correct exactly absolutely okay
all right fine so the details of how you
do that while interesting are probably
not what we should be mostly
concentrating on because the i mean the
primary thing we want to understand is
what is the user level functional design
of what's happening here
um
yes
yes so um i totally agree with
everything you said
i think that
the internals that you mentioned
uh well generally i agree they are not
very interesting for the end user
but in terms of our internal design they
might be quite interesting because they
teach us a lot about
what's happening when the data model
that we are connecting to is more
complex than just a single file or a
single flat list of things
because for instance here
well unfortunately because of these
things are half broken i can't show it
right now but one of the subtleties
which are very hard to overcome here is
that essentially
you have you can think of this backing
as if
uh each layer of data set in general
points to a different data source in
some sense
okay and and those data sources are
somehow connected
so in this case a different data source
is a table
but in other cases i can imagine
that for example you can have a nested
data set which is combined from several
arrow data sets or several flat lists of
flat files or whatnot
and then they will be attached to
different levels of a data set and
somehow they will be connected just like
here
so my point is
this model is interesting not just
because it's internals of how we connect
and manage to generate sql but also
because in general i think this will be
a pretty common situation that different
layers of this data set different levels
i understand yeah right i mean it's
what's happening is we've got this whole
octopus which is the relational database
and this is not a great image
we're taking slices of the octopus so to
speak which are yeah and and we are and
they're different slices that are being
taken that correspond to different
levels in the data set
uh yes but it's but it's the same
octopus underneath
uh yes but it's uh in terms of the
yeah if you look from this sort of high
level then then yes if you look at how
it works internally again i agree it's
probably not very interesting for the
user
but it's pretty interesting that for
example when you take a single record
out of certain table
your a stock level disappears
and then if you only have a struct
or if you if you take a single field of
a struct then your struct level
disappears and you only have a sock
where that level becomes essentially uh
what primary key points to so it i mean
the thing is
the relationship between levels
and
data sources is rather fluid
yeah i understand okay let's we're going
to run out of time here and we so can we
just see the rest of this presentation
uh it's uh pretty much it uh or the only
thing i uh wanted to say is eight of 13
so there has to be some other stuff oh
yeah that's mostly the additional
material
uh there was this uh slide with
similarities and differences was the
data container but it's mostly borrowed
from the old presentation i had
so
i guess christopher summarized this
nicely that a data container is
is more
currently more targeted towards uh more
rectangular things and also data
container necessarily well at least it
is i think it's more intended for things
which live
in the kernel or somehow close to the
kernel
while the approach that uh i am
perceiving i i don't think so why are we
saying that i mean i don't think well
maybe
maybe okay let me put it this way
uh you probably can through data
container connect to some external data
sources like relational database or
whatnot
but i thought that
the
most at least the original idea of data
container was to provide
more kind of efficient engine
uh within the kernel that allows you to
do this let's zoom out for a second okay
okay first point is
at the level of expressions
we have a very flexible way of
representing data hierarchical
you know un
you know not the same in all directions
etc etc etc etc
okay
we also have
uh but we also believe that the
underlying schema the internal schema
we will often want simple internal
schemas they might be slices of
databases they might be some kind of
you know um
thing in an arrow or whatever else
but then we've got this translation from
the external extremely flexible
expression to that internal form
and sometimes that translation is of
tabular data sometimes we can imagine
that the tabular data has little pockets
of deeper stuff of hierarchical stuff
right
but what you're showing is you can
flatten the hierarchical stuff out rob
has not done that for data container but
we could do that for data container we
could have a schema and data container
that doesn't just say this is in these
units et cetera et cetera but rather
says oh and this part is hierarchical
yeah i guess
the main point i was trying to make is
that the technology i'm developing is
mostly about translation
and it doesn't compose to what
as opposed to
certain
[Music]
internals of for example
providing efficient engine
with efficient compiler based
column types or
some internal efficient uh
selects or other primitives so to me
those things will be
i'll be kind of a client of those things
so
if they're provided
then if
all i need to have this thing working is
a set of primitives exposed to me so
that i know how to make this translation
work
i know i know i know i know i mean
because in the end there's an api i mean
like for data set
well data set in the end can fall back
to standard symbolic evaluation can it
not for doing queries
yeah
right
sure
and presumably you should be able to do
the same thing even though you know
you'd like to be able to do it at the
sql level if the thing is asking you to
compute a maya g function of something
you're going to have to pull it back out
to the expression level sure sure
but that's uh right now that's kind of a
one one way thing because then
uh
like once you convert back uh you you
kind of leave leave the convenience of
working within the backend but in the
future we might even be able to
run certain things kind of in a callback
style from the back end but that's kind
of further away
right
right
okay
yeah i'll just
yeah um i just thought i'd mention if we
try and make
if we try and make the data container
idea the rectangularish idea do too much
then i think we
you know we lose
some of the potential efficiencies
or it's very hard to keep the
efficiencies if we try and do too much
at once
yeah i agree so we're not concentrating
on that right now we're going to deal
with rectangles
and
in data container we're dealing with
rectangular stuff and what leon is doing
i think we've defined what we're talking
about the only thing which i think is
useful
is okay so we have the the function
dimensions
dimensions will take as we all know
a you know a list of lists that are
rectangularized and it'll give us a
characterization of those levels
what leonard was showing earlier we
could view as being something like
dimensions but applicable to nested
associations if i'm not mistaken uh
still with one with one addition
which is
in my approach the
mapping to generated
field names is pretty crucial
i'm sorry i don't understand if you've
got a data set which is a nested
collection of associations okay
one question is what is it schema
okay it's schema as in the thing you
were showing which is a nested which is
not
the full
um
uh
um
[Music]
um
you know
uh let's see the the
okay the whole point is you've got all
the data there and you've got this
association with with you know
a key name
going to this thing and assume that you
have this rectangularized version where
all the columns have the same keys in
them what you had there was a summary of
what the key structure is
right
um yeah but but the thing is
when i take a data set and they generate
what i call schema from it
one of the steps is to invent this uh
unique uh field names
okay but that's an internal
implementation detail that's not what
i'm talking about what i'm talking about
is you've got to be able to have some
way of specifying
that
you know in other words you've got a
nested a collection of nested
associations which are rectangular in
the sense that all the columns of a
given
thing have the same structure you
understand what i'm saying
yes but this uh this statement and this
structure is already expressed by data
set type
i i know i know i understand that i'm
saying don't go back to further back in
your in your presentation
you had a thing let's see
maybe it was that one
i'm not sure
um scroll down you had a thing where you
were showing as an expression
the skeleton the schema of how those
uh
keys were connected
yeah it's um
where is it i i i'll find it
i think it's in
expanded
no no you had it in a top level thing it
was an output line a top level output
line it showed what the schema looks
like okay it's that right hand side
thing there more or less
but it just says moon's arrow and we
could generate it by hand
yeah you mean this right the
no they don't mean that i mean you had a
thing which was a pure expression top
level expression that just said
where was it i think it was in
connection with the other data set in
connection with the um
oh
okay that's what you mean in the
relational one right yes
um
yeah it's in the demo
this one yes that one there that one
there that's what i'm talking about yeah
okay okay so that is
a
symbolic representation a simple
symbolic representation of the schema
correct
oh
yes uh for um
yeah i i i guess i guess so it just yes
so any rectangularized collection of
nested associations
has a skeleton like this
uh yeah i would say it's not the most
general one because uh because it was
for relational database i left alone
two other components of data set which
have vectors and tuples
i know i know i know i know that i know
that just like when you give a part
specification you have to have this
notion of key that represents whether it
is a
an association
key
or whether it is a part number in the
traditional positional part
representation right so similarly here
there are levels in here which should
say
instead of customers arrow you know
whatever there's a level there that is
something that represents a positionally
specified list
as opposed to
here where the elements are all
tuple-like elements
that are you know
specific keys in an association
yeah and i'll just mention steven that's
that's what i tried to address with this
data dimensions command i put together
that
okay cipher's the keys and it it uses
key lists for an association level and
it just uses a number at this stage i
mean we can think of all sorts of
different designs but you've already got
that okay yeah i've already got that
yeah for rectangular date i understand
that's what leonard has he has
rectangular data too that's what he gets
from a relational database yeah
yeah but uh if we if we look at this
spec
this spec certainly shows you
the relationship between things but
the full schema that i'm generating is
obviously i know it's much more detail
okay
but this is what you need
you could reconstruct
okay i just think this is a useful
representation which any data set you
can turn it into this kind of
representation along with the things
that represent ordinary lists
and
you know that's the thing which as rob
has said is a commonality between this
and data container
yeah so do you suggest some modified
form of this to be something that we
somehow expose or yes
yes yeah yes
simple as that yes
okay
um
and the fact that under the hood you're
doing much more elaborate complicated
things representing how this corresponds
to sql and so on that's magnificent but
it's a different thing
yeah sure i mean that was exactly the
idea why i came up with this shorter
presentation because obviously
right so i'm just saying expose that
listen i have to go in about one minute
here um we had a couple of comments on
our live stream particularly about
net train interacting with dataset
which i don't know how much we've done
on i mean can you feed you can feed a
dataset to the machine learning
functions can't you
yes
should be possible yeah yes i think that
the syntax right now for
machine learning is slightly different
than a train simply because
machine learning you can feed a data set
similar to a matrix and you can use
arrow column so you can say data set of
abc and then train on like to predict c
for example or to classify c
in net train is a bit different because
we have this port syntax
so
[Music]
we we
we have i also something that i notice
that the syntax is slightly unaligned
but you you think you can use the data
set i i use it recently okay i can
double check but yes okay listen i have
to run um
this was good and you know great
direction
and i think we we know where we're going
for us
and uh
i'm afraid we were just trying to
squeeze this in right before the
beginning of the summer school which
begins in about 20 minutes or something
so
okay good luck
okay